[Music]
who said that money can't buy happiness
yes it does and you don't have to be
rich to afford something that will make
you smile with the change you have in
your pocket you could go to the store
right now and buy one of these awesome
toys just wait until you see how much it
costs to be one of the most popular kids
in your school if this is your first
time visiting our channel don't forget
to subscribe and please give this video
a big thumbs up today we are showing you
10 kids toys and gadgets for under $10
Funko pop toys the reason why this toy
is so popular is that there is something
for everyone no matter who is your
favorite character you will probably
have the chance to find a Funko pop toy
inspired by them the company has a
hundred and eighty unique licenses for
movies TV shows comics and video games
it includes characters from Harry Potter
Marvel DC Comics and My Little Pony and
let's not forget our favorite Disney
Princesses if the one you love is not on
this list you can even create it
yourself
you can easily recognize the Funko pop
toys by their big square head with round
corners and their button eyes they also
all have one thing in common they are
adorable
Mike Becker is the one who created these
signature vinyl collectibles this kind
of figurines usually cost more than $100
online so he decided to start his own
company by making bobbleheads and with
only $9.99 for each character
he gave a chance to everyone to start a
collection for a reasonable price the
company was later bought by Mariotti who
worked hard to give them this coolness
factor until it became the famous toy we
know today if you could buy one which
character would it be ours will probably
be Elsa from frozen slime this is such a
simple toy that we are all addicted to
it as soon as we see it in our hands its
texture color and the way it moves make
it a sensory toy that both kids and
grown-ups love if you want to spend even
less money you can make it yourself with
only three ingredients glue borax and
water add the quantity that you need to
get the texture that you want then you
can add a lot of different things to
make it funnier like glitter food
coloring beads shaving cream and even
more glitter because we just love that
but if you're a little lazy like we all
are sometimes you can also buy it online
for less than $10 many teenagers started
selling homemade slime on social media
Teresa when a 13 year old is one of them
she has more than 700,000 followers on
her Instagram account rad slime this
young girl believes that slime is an
anxiety and stress reliever and the
millions of people who watch her videos
probably agree with her this is how she
makes $3,000 a month selling slime and
we think that if we stay on her
Instagram account for too long we will
soon become one of her customers digit
cubes we all know about the fidget
spinners that are now spinning in
everyone's hands all around the world
but did you know that this little gadget
had a cousin it is called the fidget
cube and like this toy we all know it
was created so we could have something
to do with our hands when we have too
much energy it can spin roll flip glide
and click it's design was inspired by a
traditional worry stone that reduces
anxiety when rubbed this gadget is
perfect to help you focus in class or
feel more relaxed during a meeting
instead of playing with a pen or
destroying a piece of Kleenex you can
find something to do that is a little
less annoying to those around you the
toy is not made to make you stop
fidgeting but so you can fidget in a
better way it is also more professional
than playing games on your phone when
you're working moreover you don't have
to recharge it and you can play as much
as you want this toy was created with
the support of many people by
crowdfunding this gadget the company
received almost 6.5 million dollars this
is one of the best fundraising campaigns
ever the fidget cube was one of the most
popular toys even before people got the
chance to play with it we have never
seen something like that before magnetic
putty this is one of the best
educational toys to learn how magnets
work and even as grown-ups we'd love to
see how this strange liquid reacts when
it is in contact with a magnet like any
other putty it can be molded stretched
bounced and torn but this added a little
magic to the mix to make it move without
touching it we can create funny
characters with it let the magnetic
putty swallow the magnet or simply see
it move closer to us with a super strong
magnet you can control it like a snake
charmer you can even turn it into a
magnet so it can pick up small
talak objects but how does that thing
work actually it is really simple to
make that toy you just need to add
ferric iron powder to regular silly
putty this is how it becomes magnetic
and the reason why it can swallow a
magnet is that the force is stronger
inside the putty it is just like there
are millions of tiny magnets inside this
toy we can only imagine all the things
we could do with this silly toy we feel
like little scientists when we play with
it and no matter how old we are seeing
this toy move is just fascinating there
are so many colors of magnetic putty
like black blue or pink but we will take
the silver one to make it look like it
is really out of this world
special straws this thing seems so
simple though we never thought of a
world without it but years ago people
used a piece of rye grass to drink it
seems disgusting and it actually was as
there were residues and the straw could
easily break this is why in the 1880s
Marvin stone came up with the idea of
rolling a piece of paper around a pencil
and making it stay in place with glue
that's how the modern straw we all know
is created most people still use paper
straws in the 1960s but the plastic
straw became more and more popular until
it was what most people used in the
1970s and since then we had the
opportunity to transform this little
thing in any way
a decade later Eric Lipson field more
than a hundred patents for his
inventions but with so many ideas for
drinking straws some of them were a
little too crazy to become popular and
this is also how we came up with the
funny straws that we can use this toys
some of the best things we found online
include glasses that you can use to
drink and straws that glow in the dark
if you lose your drink at a party but
the funniest one is probably the straw
that you can build in any shape you want
this will motivate any kid to drink
their orange juice in the morning and
adults won't resist the temptation of
being a little childish sometimes to My
Little Pony we have searched a lot of
our favorite dolls and toys online but
the best ones we found for the lowest
price are these adorable animals
inspired by my little pony you can now
buy all your favorite characters from
the show like Rainbow Dash Twilight
Sparkle Pinkie Pie or Applejack whether
you want to make them live magical
stories or simply add them to your
collection there is something for
everyone
and don't think that these toys are only
for little girls there's a whole fan
club of adults who believe that
friendship is magic grown-up men who
love my little pony call themselves the
bronies this is a community of people
who live and breathe everything related
to the show
and they are not the stereotypical Pony
lovers you would imagine they look just
like the men that you see every day and
the only thing that they have in common
is their obsession and they are not
alone
10,000 bronies attended the BroNYCon
convention
it isn't about guys liking a girl show
it's about the community that they
created around it and if you don't
believe us just watch the documentary a
brony tale how much do you love my
little pony we probably don't like it as
much as them but we still want to add a
toy to our collection fabric paint pens
children are really creative this could
be a great quality but not when they're
showing off their skills on the table
the walls or their clothes but you don't
have to worry anymore because these
fabric paint pens are made for exactly
that it contains permanent color that is
designed not to wash out of clothing or
fade when you wash it it is perfect to
paint thin lines and you don't even have
to wash brushes afterward you can use
stencils rubber stamps color between the
lines or simply use them to draw so just
take old t-shirts and jeans and turn
them into your new favorite outfit there
are so many things you can do with shoes
bags shirts pillows shorts and even more
fabric paint pens have become so popular
that you can even turn them into a work
of art one of the newest trends is
drawing on diapers yes you heard it
right this is what babies wear before
they learn how to use the toilet dirty
diaper laundry shared some of the best
creations including Mario Brothers The
Grinch and a unicorn so no matter how
old the child is they can either become
artists or wear these creations and as
grown-ups we would love our best friend
to use her skills to help us make a
custom shirt ours will probably be
covered with Disney Princesses pokemon
cards we all wanted to be the very best
like no one ever was but we all had to
start somewhere and that was by buying
our first pokemon cards this game was
really popular in the 1990s as all the
kids spent their spare cash to buy these
cards and trade them with their friends
and with Pokemon go in 2016 this toy was
trending again each card had a name a
type and an amount of health points we
played these cards on the field and used
these pocket monsters attacks to knock
out the opponent this toy was our most
prized possession when we were 10 years
old but did you know that it could be
worth much more today if you manage to
keep a sealed box from the original
release of Pokemon you could make a ton
of money and if you have the first
edition box it could be worth more than
$8,000 each unopened card could cost
between 20 and 200 dollars the most
popular is the rare Charizard which
could be worth almost $4,500 we never
thought that we could make so much money
with the pokemon cards that cost less
than $10 unfortunately even if we kept
our cards most of them are damaged but
we don't care because it was worth it to
have such an amazing childhood
friendship bracelets this is probably
the cheapest toy you could ever find but
it is also the most valuable it is a
symbol of love and friendship
we all remember just sitting around with
our friends and making bracelets for
every one of them all we needed was
strands of a variety of colors and
someone to show us how to make our first
bracelet some of them were really easy
to make but the best of us could also
create something really impressive
but do you know the story behind this it
all started in Central America but it
was first seen in the u.s. in the 1970s
according to the tradition if someone
gave you a bracelet you should wear it
until the cord wears out and falls
naturally to honor the hard work of your
friend this is why our arms were covered
by these fun creations and we didn't
have the right to put any scissors near
them friendship bracelets are so popular
nowadays that people can actually spend
hundreds of dollars to buy one even the
best jewelry store started selling them
but even if we are not rich we all have
something that is worth so much more a
best friend that can make a personalized
and perfectly imperfect friendship
bracelet just for us fidget spinners if
you haven't heard about it you have
probably been living under a rock for
the past couple of months but even if
you know about this little gadget we're
going to talk about it again because it
is so fascinating the fidget spinner
spins in our hand or on a table for a
couple of seconds and that's pretty much
it but no matter what we can't stop
watching it and making it spin
just one more time it has become the
latest trend in high school and just by
owning one of these unique toys you can
get a lot of attention and become really
popular for only a dollar and that's
even better if you can show off your
skills with this toy some people can
make them spin on their fingers their
toes their forehead or even their nose
unfortunately this gadget was so popular
that it had to be banned at many schools
the toy was supposed to help kids stay
focused in class and feel less anxious
but when everyone started buying it just
because it was cool it became a major
distraction or maybe the teachers were
just jealous and decided that no one
could have it anyway some people
complained that they couldn't stop
looking at their friends trying out new
tricks and the sound was annoying them
during class this was when things
started to get serious as many schools
decided to ban this toy do you think
they were right to do that tell us what
you think in the comments section below
and that's it for 10 kids toys and
gadgets for under $10 for more stories
like this don't forget to watch 10
strange reasons kids toys were banned
thanks for watching
[Music]